[Musique]
toute la journée la police scientifique
a passé les deux du drame au peigne fin
pour tenter de retrouver le meurtrier
d'éric masson policier de 36 ans à ba
thuy ces policiers habillés en civil
remarque une transaction de stupéfiants
et décident de contrôler les individus
c'est à ce moment que l'une des
personnes contrôlées sort une arme et
tire froidement sur l'un des policiers
et pourtant c'est arrivé qu'on puisse
mourir au travail alors on exerce pour
métier de policier est à la fois un
drame était sans doute un tournant d'une
extrême gravité par rapport à ce qui se
passe en france la lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants
partout sur le territoire national
s'apparente à une guerre
cette guerre nous la menons grâce à des
soldats ces soldats sont les policiers
les gendarmes de france aujourd'hui
soldats le registre guerrier très viril
voilà peu impressionnés etc je ne suis
pas sûr qu'ils soient le plus efficaces
donc est-ce qu'on peut réfléchir à ce
qui peut être efficace en termes de
santé publique la lutte contre les
trafiquants de drogue c'est une guerre
une guerre que nous menons maintenant
depuis plusieurs années avec beaucoup de
détermination et je partage surtout la
détermination des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui sera encore renforcée il
faut s'en donner les moyens quand on
fait la guerre il faut être à la hauteur
des enjeux
or le ce qui caractérise ce gouvernement
dans beaucoup de domaines y compris dans
celui de la sécurité
c'est justement de ne pas être à la
hauteur et de ne pas se donner les
moyens mais le pays en europe qui avons
la politique la plus répressive depuis
des années et avec un échec total c'est
à dire que la consommation explose donc
à la fois une question de santé publique
et la question ces trafics qu'il faut le
dire pourrissent la vie des habitants
des quartiers populaires je vois que
grandit l'enjeu de la dépénalisation du
cannabis comme proposition pour
justement casser les trafics
je crois qu'il faut qu'aujourd'hui on
ouvre ce débat là lorsque je vois qu'en
parallèle de l'action du ministre de
l'intérieur qui est celle de d'embêter
quelques dealers et bien la majorité en
marche aujourd'hui propose la
dépénalisation du cannabis je pense
qu'il ya un problème on voit bien qu'il
ya un tout petit problème le problème
c'est pas de légaliser le problème c'est
d'interdire de façon extraordinaire
concrètes et pas uniquement dans les
textes si l'individu en question si le
criminel si l'assassin en question est
interpellé dans la sphère d'avignon que
nous ne soyons pas surpris de son profil
parce qu'on ne tire pas sur la police
par hasard dans la rue et il est quand
même je crois que nous pouvons quand
même roman anticipé le fait qu' il aura
été malheureusement déjà connu des
services de police qui est à l'origine
du drame s'est pas uniquement trafic de
drogue mais c'est de baisser
l'immigration massive et l'insécurité et
la criminalité flamboyante qui en est la
conséquence donc la première des choses
à faire comme quand vous appelez le
plombier est ce que vous avez une fille
doit y est après un show ce que fait le
plombier qui ferme le lot intervenu à la
sulfateuse pour le candidat à la
présidentielle de petits extraits
regarder ce que dit à xavier bertrand
macron est un calculateur froid
destructeur emmanuel macron sait que son
adversaire le plus dangereux c'est la
droite républicaine c'est pour cela
qu'ils cherchent à la briser à partir de
mercredi 12 mercredi 12 vous pourrez
regarder la veille sur le site mais
d'obtenir les doses qui sont disponibles
et cela quel que soit votre âge vous
savez je suis maire de nez ça et membre
du parti des républicains jusqu'à
aujourd'hui officiellement vous vous
faites de la politique moi je serai
d'administration territoriale
c'est au tour du maire de nice christian
estrosi de claquer la porte des
républicaines mais dont je cite la
dérive d'une faction qui semble avoir
pris en otage la direction du parti pour
faire capoter le projet d'alliance entre
l air em et l air aux régionales en paca
fait sourire ah oui beaucoup
c'est drôle comment vous êtes fait vous
les journalistes parisiens
je crois que vous ne connaissez pas la
france vous ne savez pas qui si les
partis politiques on s'en fout